[Music]
welcome back to another amazing episode
of the careful boys where we are
extremely careful and today we have mr
jason cheney in the building hey
hey
we were just talking about this you know
earlier in the day so let's get back to
it we were just talking about wanting an
updated 2022
ranking of asians presented by jason
cheney what rank okay asians number one
the black people
black people no no no um no even even
within asia even within asian it's like
black a lot of people yeah i was like i
could see how that could work yeah
we're not even connected as a continent
dude i know way more black dudes that do
kung fu than asian dudes for sure that's
true hundred percent i know at least i
know at least like four or five they got
a hell of swag in the outfit yeah and
they make it look cool we don't know
like five or six asians that do kung fu
no i really don't i know i know like you
know i used to train with a couple of
people
the only mainstream kung fu song is by
black people
that's true thank you thank you ryan and
the only kung fu group i know the
wu-tang clan
yeah that's true they made it kind of
way cooler yeah
so so back to your range of black people
is at the top of the asians list so
what's under what's under black odb odb
is here yeah yeah odp
but what i never really thought about
ranking it and i would like to be very
specific
wait where did this question come from
like what's the concept earlier in the
morning he's like oh because we were
talking about like first he was talking
drunk on vietnamese people because why
not it's easy too right and then he's
like and then he's like well you guys
haven't done your rankings asian
rankings i just thought you guys did
because you guys are you know i was like
okay we are a pretty prominent asian
like
voice out there and i think it's about
time we create the hierarchy of asians
yeah yeah starting with black people at
the top like you said
obviously korean supremacy yeah koreans
pretty up there korean spirit
and world war ii though they weren't
really up there and i'd have to say my
ancestors were kind of up there but
these days koreans are really crushing
it dude but even when they were losing
they're like korea number one that's
true that's true they know how to lose
while being number one yeah they're good
sports they are well
that's another thing is like what
dictates to be number one like
how crazy they are or economics
what's your criteria yeah whatever 20 22
rankings by jason cheney all right uh
being the most savage
okay who will win in the war oh i see i
see i like this that's a that's a new
take it's a new take because i mean like
savage as in like as in like like jungle
jungle asian savage or you mean like you
talking about like civilized versus
savaged or like you're talking about
like
war dog crazy like i'll bite you like no
no like crazy like okay so who's number
one who's number one like blanca or m
bison kind of said oh okay okay okay
yeah who's number one savage g then
probably chinese nah chinese is a [ __ ]
dude viet congs were savage bro vietcong
doesn't have that many people 2022 dog
22 20 22.
we're talking about population he's like
voted world war ii chinese i haven't
heard somebody rep viet cong like this
in front of you yeah dude did you who
wrapped it like that the viet cong
they're crazy
dude the stories that they damn man yeah
i mean gangsters these vcs did all right
those guys are retired
he's saying that china has the most uh
people to you know most people knows
most money yeah but chinese people
aren't dangerous though chinese people
will [ __ ] like sell you a lot of [ __ ]
that's dangerous dude i feel like china
i feel like china just holds the world
like this and at any point
yeah because they're really polite they
don't want to show that that's not
savage to me savage is like genghis khan
[ __ ] i'll [ __ ] come and blow up your
whole village and then [ __ ] all your
[ __ ] lizards
or whatever like [ __ ] i'll grab all your
[ __ ] village monkeys and then [ __ ]
make them play drums and [ __ ] or
something
yeah so that kind of savage but you
still want to win do you know i feel
like chinese people if they really
wanted to they'll be very polite and
then still be savage they'll be like hey
can i please have your women and then
they'll the people will say no and
they'll go okay please and then grab
them really hard
and then
and then and then rate them and smile in
their face be like that's kind of savvy
it's like the intro to a glorious
bastard
has there any jews
he's very polite but also they're down
they business yeah you know
because right now they want what they
want yeah yeah because right now their
war is like hey we're friendly right and
he goes yeah you know what you ever
watched tick tock oh he's like yeah yeah
watch your legs watch your family whole
family watch okay okay you guys get
really stupid okay let me just take the
economy away from your whole country
make the economy away son wanted to be a
doctor no influencer now
that's true
you want a barbie doll we make it here
their war is economically superior so
who could who could put up a fight
against china yeah uh in asia
singapore way too small
wait a
but every single chinese want to go to
singapore to gamble right because
there's no gambling allowed in your
communists
or macau that's how they're going to win
is they're going to drain all of china's
money through gambling ah
because when a chinese person walks in a
casino they cannot resist they cannot
resist that's very true yeah so who's
number two
i want to say north korea
[Laughter]
you want to say that
i want to say why did you laugh
why north korea just the way you said it
was so like north korea i i because
they're so um because
he killed his own uncle that's number
one don't point at me
this guy no no but also there uh i feel
like they have they study
war for a really long time yeah but they
got outdated equipment that's her truth
that's where they're their equipment's
gonna break but you know what it's all
about execution i feel like they would
execute
better than like chinese people could
they work harder exactly yeah and they
they could eat crickets
they never get hungry
people can eat something
yeah i mean true the guy created yeah
but they still get hungry chinese people
are still more civilized than you know
north koreans that's true that's true
you could survive longer and in a
harsher condition who's number three
then number three um
i would say probably uh
probably
vietnamese people vietnamese people you
know yeah why are you apologetic about
that
it was reluctant yeah you got that it
was very lucky it was very salty
probably
throw this guy a bone
here why you got to give him a
participation award for him
because joe was repping it so hard
that's why who are you trying to appease
man north korea i think they wouldn't
even make it three miles outside of
north korea because they get they're
already hungry if you're leaving hungry
they're already malnourished if you're
leaving hungry dude
that's game over but if you're leaving
like everywhere else has food though you
know what i mean you could steal the
corn from everywhere they're leaving has
an abundance of food all the north
koreans are gonna leave their country
and be like yo this is [ __ ] cool
in my mind i feel like they're going to
fall victim to like you know like if
they left the country they would see so
much [ __ ] that's interesting they'll
just not be angry
it's like if you brought you know like a
bill of ted's when they tried to bring
like historical figures to present day
and then they were all just like wanting
to do this other [ __ ] like an exercise
bike that's true like joan of arc wanted
to go to aerobics class [ __ ] like that
that's the perfect night or would it be
more like the shawshank redemption when
that dude spent his whole life in prison
came out to a new world he never saw
before and then felt yeah but they cut
the part where he saw the [ __ ] n64
and spent the rest of his time yeah
playing that's on the deleted scene he
did that before he hung himself yeah
that was in the director's cut when
north korea comes to invade the rest of
uh asia all we gotta do is give them all
phones with the all unlimited access to
only fans oh yeah their hands will
explode their heads will literally
explode they're like yo people are doing
this and recording it that's the
drawback of like sheltered like because
even in old movies like when villa when
the uh savage people attack and they see
all this like cool [ __ ] it's distracting
man that's all we gotta do if they if
they invade america right we get all of
our influencer girls to line up and
[ __ ] have a torque contest and
mesmerize them and when they're like oh
[ __ ] i've never seen ass so fat and
[ __ ] juicy and it's like shaking and
it's all in sync and they're like what
are we gonna do that's when you grab the
[ __ ] guns that don't even work that's
how we fight back against china
the old aso fat campaign strategy
always works but what if they already
have so much sex in north korea because
they're not doing other things you know
what i mean so they
yeah so sex havers interesting yeah
who's that
um in the savage well actually you
didn't really kind of touch on number
three yeah why is vietnam means savage
yeah
what puts them in third place because
also um
they're very real really
yeah and um i actually thought they were
it was crazy that they had any covert
protocols that vietnamese can catch
kovac and that's true actually because
they're so resilient do they not they
have kova there no i think so i don't
know how but they're
all my vietnamese friends have never
gotten sick my whole life have you ever
seen a vietnamese man with a flu before
it's usually the vietnamese that are
mixed with chinese that got flus
that's you that's a me man yeah these
guys know they got cozy you're
vietnamese though
how many times have you had covered now
every time i have the cold whip chinese
side yeah me and all my homies we went
down to mexico to eat street tacos when
we crossed the cross back we all had the
shits except for the vietnamese homie no
but the thing is yeah but the thing is
you didn't have the same taco do i mean
we all got carasada i know but the thing
is like the vietnamese guy's taco it
doesn't have the bad stuff in it but the
rest of you had the best stuff how did
you do that was that bill cosby you
[ __ ] put other things and then he
doesn't have the badge so he's poisoned
you guys so he's saying vietnamese
people can't be trusted
so like you go to mexico sometimes you
know how they have like like the hot
plate yeah where they cook the meat yeah
yeah they sometimes there's mostly
corners so the meat is in the corners
and then his is in the center his meat
so they distributed and then the
vietnamese guy he didn't eat the bad one
duh
defenders saw the viet guy and went hey
you get this one yeah yeah yeah he goes
you're number three let your weird ass
friends eat the shitty stuff
you live the good life
so that's why you're chinese friends
brother
doma brother he's like some kind of
sympathizer
should have been you guys you guys want
i think you guys won
but they're in mexico yeah yeah yeah
yeah
he's a huge history speaking english
number four
full metal dragon it's a whack movie by
the way
what other asian countries is there oh
there's mongol i think that's all of
them
malaysia philippines
japan
taiwan south korea either i don't want
to give with them because they have
squid game and they're killing it
yeah they don't need any more accolades
probably probably korea because they're
getting a little softer i would say
south korea south korea is number four
it was gonna be number three but because
because of bts and squid
and you know the really nice things and
then korean drama game was really nice
yeah it was really nice it was about
like killing each other it'd be great
for the country they did the greater for
the country
and it's more entertainment yeah great
for the colors
they have samsung and yeah
yeah
yeah other hyundai
yeah i mean
living it up dude bcd you know that's
enough bcd tofu
wow that's sunday
oh brother
can't forget that
gotta eat korean food like at least
twice a month at least
yeah you gotta have it
so that's yeah yeah something like where
does taiwan rank on this list it's not
up there man
no i wouldn't want to i wouldn't want to
it's just because
we we were you know we ran away after uh
we did no we ran away because we had a
civil war and then
we ran away but the thing is
because we didn't want to have a
communist country so it's a good thing
you know and we ran away and we want to
be accepting so of others and ourselves
so it's too soft you're saying
it's not too soft it's a little soft
okay but don't i don't like the way you
said that yeah
you know i i don't identify as japanese
because i'm an american but what about
the the good old japanese people what
about those samurais yeah i don't
identify what about the really great
japanese historically awesome people
but you like japanese i don't like the
way you said that
i don't like that silence
what do you do there i don't like that
no i think japanese is like second i
changed my because i forgot about them
yeah japanese is nice how are you gonna
forget about sushi dude i know i forgot
about the japanese i feel so unseen dude
and then what so north korea is third
now yeah north korea has stored now
because japanese people they have so
much pent-up anger
always you know you know america took
away japan's military i know but the
thing is it's all about the people it's
not about what they're doing but people
are [ __ ] bro hey i don't think so bro
but japan is having a birthing problem
so it couldn't that be bad for the
future that's because the guys can't
[ __ ] because they can't [ __ ] keep
missing no they go
they jack off
too much it's everywhere it was behind
me the whole time
their [ __ ] shows are always ruining
the sperm count [ __ ] by marco polo
marco
wait what do you think is the reason for
the birthing too much [ __ ] that's it
doesn't go on the face it goes in the
[ __ ] that's how you make a baby they're
missing that's what they're missing yeah
too much [ __ ] too much and it's like
eight people at one time too so it's
like eight loads that go nowhere it
should be the other way
if you want to make babies you don't do
five guys on one girl you do one guy on
five girls that's how you make more
babies that's how you make a more baby
yeah that's pretty crazy that [ __ ] is
purely japanese that's like a japanese
thing isn't it no i think they do it in
america they just don't call it book but
it originated in japan it did
like they create like that's their [ __ ]
porn history is one of my favorite
topics we talked about you guys go
ever if you guys ever go to japan okay
and you go to a udon restaurant yeah
okay make sure you order [ __ ] exactly
here you go on your server
[ __ ] udon it's one of the best
things what makes it different than
regular [ __ ] just no [ __ ] yeah
it's really cool it's a regular word
what does it mean spilling all over
no way it's like it just means pouring
it just means [ __ ] pouring like black
so [ __ ] udon i'm really fascinated by
the udon actually
why is it different than regular udon
there's a load of [ __ ] on it like this
more premium toppings because it's like
a lot of it looks like a lot of people
come on your face when you're eating it
no it literally looks like a lot of [ __ ]
because they they they get like taro or
like this mounted potato and it's got
this like
comish texture oh the slimy thing is
yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah on top of the the udon and stuff i
like that they call it
hot twist it's just calm
no it's mountain potato dude it's
mountain potatoes shut up
okay you want to eat some exquisite
mountain potato
goo google it right now
google
it tastes really good it tastes really
salty and acidic but
i'm not even joking dude it is a real
thing i hope you're not joking because
now i'm looking at [ __ ] yeah it's
real you could i mean you can use it in
in like a sentence whatever no one's
gonna think you're talking about come on
a face but when you listen to americans
and then like when americans hear it in
japan they're like oh my god
oh my god what's the equipment what's
the english equivalent to that like
saying gangbang and you're talking about
gangs yeah probably yeah yeah oh yeah
that's true or a circle jerk i'm just
kidding or i'm going to do missionary
work oh yeah something like that yeah
i'm looking at [ __ ] udon it does look
like regular udon i don't see a gooey
mountain potato substance that looks
that's not authentic dude
just look at it just just show it just
turn your safe search off first
it's a bunch of guys around a bowl
okay what is that [ __ ] udon see you
know what that's there it looks like
there's more stuff so we really have to
go all the way to japan for that we
can't just get it you can get a second
street in san pedro in the meantime
who's number five
um what's another one that's it
philippines
who is who was at the very bottom like
who is like they they're the least
savage of all countries probably taiwan
no oh no what
or singapore
because they're
everything he is
are you looking at me there's six other
guys in here
asians with the last name done
yeah for real dude
it's not even like uh explanation it's
just this is what it is this is what it
is
this is the gospel now i see yeah
they're tied any asian who reps both
taiwan and singapore probably the least
savage in the group i do like hanging
out with my chinese friends much more
because they're less aggressive to
compare to who korean and japanese no
way japanese people are not super
aggressive yeah you ever seen tara's
house bro i don't think i think you got
it all mixed up oh you know what it's
because i chill with a bunch of [ __ ]
up people hey what are you saying about
us are you talking about your japanese
like friends yeah yeah you have like the
most gangster japanese friends
[Laughter]
i should hang out at the anime expo they
have much more nicer asians i think most
people that go to anime expo are like
it's not even that asian anymore i feel
like
it's so like diverse these days it's
great well they all identify as asians
so i accept them yeah that's true you
could be honored we love you all
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you